we're asked to solve 2x is equal to the
principal square root of 14 plus 10x
plus 2. so whenever you see one of these
equations that have a variable we need
to solve for under the radical sign what
you want to do is you want to isolate
the radical sign and then square both
sides essentially to get rid of it but
you have to be very careful when you do
that because when you square radical
sign you actually lose the information
that you were taking the principle or
the positive square root and so when you
get your final answers you got to make
sure that they work because some of the
answers might have been based on taking
the negative square root and just to
make sure i guess the best way to see
that tangibly is to try to do this
problem and let's see if that shows up
here
so the first thing we want to do is
isolate this radical sign best way to do
that is to get rid of this 2 here the
best way to do that is to subtract 2
from the right but if we do it from the
right we also have to do it from the
left and so our equation becomes on the
left hand side we have 2x minus 2 and
then on the right hand side that is
equal to
the square root of 14 plus 10 x and
these guys right over there cancel out
and so now we can square both sides
so now we can square both sides
of this equation and this is the step
where we're losing information because
when we square the right hand side right
over here when we square the right hand
side and this is the whole point of
squaring it we're just going to get 14
we're going to get 14 plus 10x
and the reason why we lost information
is this we would have also gotten this
if this was the negative square root but
if this was a negative square root this
would have been a fundamentally
different problem here would have had a
negative square root out here but we're
getting the same thing over here so one
of our answers might actually satisfy
this equation as opposed to the one that
we need to solve which is the one that
doesn't have the negative over there so
the best way to do it is just to square
solve and then see which of these work
and which of them don't by substituting
back in the original equation so we get
14 plus 10x on the right hand side on
the left hand side and we've done this
many times in previous videos if you
square something if you have a plus b
squared this is equal to a squared plus
2 a b plus b squared you can do the
distributive property twice literally
expanding this out and multiplying or
you could do foil if you like that
better but it is good to recognize the
special case of squaring a binomial it
fits this pattern
so 2x squared the whole quantity is
going to be 4x squared so if you take 2x
and i squared the whole thing i get 4
x squared
and then i'm going to take the product
of both of these terms so 2x times
negative 2 is negative 4x negative 4x
times 2 is negative
negative 8x let me be clear how i'm
getting these so this is this term right
here is 2x
squared
this term over here this term over here
is 2 times 2x
times negative 2. so it's equivalent to
this term right over here and then
finally i'm going to have to square this
right over here so negative 2 squared is
just positive 4. so this is analogous to
this term right over there
and now we have a quadratic equation and
we can simplify it so it looks like a
traditional quadratic equation so we
could do is get rid of this 14 plus 10x
on the right-hand side once again best
way to do that subtract 14 from both
sides
subtract 14 from both sides and subtract
10x from both sides
and subtract 10x from both sides and we
are left with
the right hand side is easy 14 minus 14
is 0. 10x minus 10x is 0. we're just
left with a 0. on the left hand side we
have 4
x squared negative 8x minus 10x is
negative 18x and then 4 minus 14 4 minus
14 is negative 10 and that is going to
be equal to zero
and
everything here is divisible by
two and so what we can do is just to
simplify this a little bit is multiply
both sides of this equation
is multiply both sides of this equation
by one-half
so let's multiply both which is the same
thing as dividing it by two
multi-dividing both sides by two or
multiplying both sides by one-half and
what that does on the left-hand side
one-half times 4 is 2
x-squared or one-half times 4x squared
is 2x squared one-half times negative
18x is negative 9x and then one-half
times negative 10 is negative 5 and on
the right hand side we have this is
equal to zero
and so we can let's see if we can factor
this out we can try factoring by
grouping and when you factor by grouping
we're looking for two numbers so we're
looking for two numbers eight let's call
them a and b that add up to negative
nine because we're going to break up
this term right here into
ax and bx so they need to add up to
negative nine and their product needs to
be the product of two times negative 5.
so a times b needs to be equal to 2
times
2 times negative 5
or negative 10. and since their product
is a negative number one of these has to
be positive and one of these has to be
negative and we've covered this in we've
we've shown why this works and i think
many many many videos ago but you might
want to look that up if you think i'm
doing some type of magic voodoo right
over here so let's think about numbers
that that add up to negative 9 and whose
product is negative 10. so if you look
at 1 and 10 if you make one of these
negative and one of these positive you
will either get positive or negative 9.
and so that looks pretty good so if you
have 1 and negative 10 they add up to
negative 9 and you take the product you
get
when you take the product you get
negative 10 1 times negative 10 is
negative 10. so let's break up this
negative 9x into
let's break it up into
a positive 1x and a negative and a
negative 10x so all i did obviously 1x
minus 10x is negative 9x and that's why
you see why they have these coefficients
have to add up to negative 9. and then
we have the
2 x squared out here and then we have a
minus 5 out here and you should just see
this negative 9x is the same thing as i
wrote in green right over here and if
you don't like this factoring by
grouping the other option really is to
use the quadratic formula and you'll
just get the answers but this is a
little bit cleaner especially if you
have a gut feeling and the people who've
written this problem seem to like to
give us integer solutions or close to
integer solutions so if you have a gut
feeling it's going to be one of those
factoring by grouping is not a bad idea
and so we group we can group these two
guys and then we can group and then we
can group these two guys so we could
call this plus
negative 10x
so that we can group it just like that
and so in this first expression right
here we can factor out an x so this
becomes x times
two x
plus 1
that's this right over here and in the
second term over here we can factor out
looks like we can factor out a negative
5. so you factor out a negative 5 you
get negative 5 negative 10x divided by
negative 5 is 2x negative 5 divided by
negative 5 is just 1.
and now we can factor out a 2x plus 1
from both of these terms and so i'll do
that over here so if you factor out a 2x
plus 1
you get
2 x plus 1
times
you have this
x over here and then you have this minus
5 over here
and this isn't clear what i did here i
just literally factored these guys out
or another way to think is if you
multiply if you distributed this
times that and if you if you multiply 2x
times 2x plus 1 times x and 2x plus 1
times negative 5 this is exactly what
you would get right over here so another
way of thinking of this factoring this
out is that we undistributed it i guess
is one way to think about it but anyway
this equation is now 2x plus 1 times x
minus 5 is equal to 0 and obviously if
you have the product of two numbers and
they equal to zero that means one or
both of them need to be equal to zero so
we get
either two x plus one is equal to zero
or or i guess it could be and or
x minus 5 is equal to 0. when you solve
this you get you can subtract 1 from
both sides you get 2x is equal to
negative 1. divide both sides by 2. you
get x is equal to negative 1 half
or
x
x is actually it's not and or it's just
or either one of these will satisfy if
either one of these are equal to 0 then
this will satisfy the equation although
both of them can be
and so and then or satisfies that
obviously so if and then for here x
minus 5 equals 0. add 5 to both sides
you get x i'll write it down here you
get x is equal to 5.
or x is equal to 5. now remember you
can't just say that these are the
solutions because one of these solutions
might be for the case where this was the
negative square root so we have to
substitute back into our original
equation and see if they work so first
let's try the situation with x is equal
to negative one half if you do that you
get i'll do it up here
i'm running out of real estate i'll do
it up here so let's try the situation
when x is equal to negative one-half
then this equation becomes two times
negative one-half
is equal to
the principal square root
the principal square root
the principle square root of 14
plus 10 times negative one-half 10 times
negative one-half
plus two and so we get negative one is
equal to
10 times negative one half is negative
five
fourteen times negative five fourteen
times sorry fourteen plus negative five
is nine
the principal square root of nine is
three
so we get 3 plus 2 which is clearly not
the case this does not work negative 1
half does not work this is an extraneous
solution and you're like wait why did
that even show up when we did the math
because if you think about it if this
was the negative square root if this
equation happened to be have a negative
square root over here then this would be
a negative 3 and then it would work and
then it would work so this was the
solution for when we were taking the
negative square root but this is the
principal square root and so negative
one-half does not work so let's try x is
equal to five
i'll do it right over here so if x is
equal to five then we get two times five
so that's ten
should be equal to the principal square
root of 14 plus 10
times 5. well 10 times 5 is 50 plus 14
is 64
plus 2. this is clearly true the
principal square root of 64 is 8 eight
plus two is ten so our answer for this
radical equation is x is equal to five
it is not x equals negative one half
this is extraneous